[Music]
well hello everyone
and thank you we've always wondered what
could happen if our crazy rabbits were
unleashed upon the world of mayo today
the dream is reality and to talk about
this unexpected encounter it is my great
honor to welcome a very special guest
someone I truly admire
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Miyamoto son
[Applause]
thank you for coming you're sorry to
have you today so what what have you
brought
oh you well what did you bring this is a
right side paprika a one of the weapon
from this game Wow cool I'm sure you'll
love it I brought one for you okay oh
thank you
[Applause]
listen we can't have a conversation
where a Corral no ghostery go to the
Chiodo show these are a little bit
different from the weapons you see in
Ghost Recon how are you - oh yeah very
different weapons very different worlds
this one is I think very effective in
the world of my own rabbit
so should do well
and I'm so proud of you be soft
long-standing collaboration with
Nintendo
you know from the ds2 the Wii and more
recently for the impressive launch of
the switch you know it has always been
we have always been inspired by Nintendo
and by all the great work you have been
able to do so it's now home buddy
I know it's more UVs on your neck your
look without a target over diamonds yes
thank you very much for all the work
that we've been able to do together over
the years with Ubisoft Mora they article
did you wondering where that doesn't
listen it
I mean leaves it's already been about 25
years since you and I first met
there is reto any gluten Vinny you guys
are Nobu so cocoa Home Instead the video
they took the maratti
I know I shall I know BD only told your
stylist Emerson and every year at e3
you're kind enough to invite me to your
booth and we get to take lots of
pictures and videos and I've even
recorded messages for Ubisoft employees
in the past assault on being in a movie
I know Kai has no medicine no ps-aguié
Nintendo game y matado contiguous so
over the years I've always felt a deep
heartfelt passion that Ubisoft
developers have for Nintendo and it's
characters disorder Bohdan a bougwan
onizuka how selfish their dive of this
gaga boy
stay there and Combaticons but on the
other hand because we're both software
developers we've also looked at each
others as kind of rivals and enter tried
to see who could make the best software
Kodama I know it was not god of its
known um we're at our university but
we're not sick you know my name or dive
it's like bad on the schedule and also
you know it's not humorous to go Greek
isomers
but of course I've known the Rabbids
characters for many years and I have
many rabbits figures decorating my desk
Wow so I've always been a fan of the
characters and their humor the Aconcagua
hanashi wa ato de la vista Cadorna you
moko gave no naka de mississippi turkish
watanabe nice thoughts so since this
project first started i've been very
excited to see what kind of humour the
rabbits could bring to the mario world
they thought that i know there is a
sunny AutoKey then that is a nice toast
i got a license so when I met David Ison
who is the
a creative director of this game
when I when I met Davide son I had just
just one condition for this project
disciple junkies of the game poker so
you put up the home game we are not
there Mario de mama discovered on an
agenda nor gave matsutake tourists
I said whatever you do don't try to make
a jump game or a Mario platformer try to
make a Mario game that has never been
made before y'all got that it is and
it's great and I can tell you it was an
exciting very exciting challenge for all
our teams and I think we've done
something you will load so thank you
very much for giving us the chance to to
perform on this game hi Antonio no for
Europa discrete okinawan Amida give
Novato Donnie Segura IDO you be a sci-fi
action game ooh Santos cut education and
they're constructed Tansen of strategy
game do you wanna know Tonto Co tempo no
he gave me the calamus and so of course
because the game is being made in Europe
it has a very unique flavor to it and of
course Ubisoft is very good at making
action games but this game in particular
has a great layer of strategy and
tactics to it but with a very good pace
ya know it's it's going to be fresh
actually and so no let's welcome
zabi a you know the producer of the game
and he will show us the game
[Applause]
[Applause]
finally finally we can talk about this
project so we've been working on this
game for more than three years now and
to be at e3 today on this stage it's
just super exciting so what is this game
exactly
so Mario plus rabbit's kingdom battle is
a tactical adventure exclusive for the
Nintendo switch and let's check right
away some gameplay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the rabbits have been teleported into
the the Mushroom Kingdom
and it made the world completely
unstable and chaotic so Mario as a true
hero wants to save the day but this time
with some new friends
[Music]
[Music]
and at first they don't really know each
others but in the end they will form
this dream team that will potentially
save the Mushroom Kingdom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and as the game is a turn-based tactical
adventure game combat is a really big
part of the concept so you'll fight wave
after wave and rabbit that somehow
turned bad and what we see here is just
the very beginning of the game so it'll
be perfect to talk about the combat
basics so the two flags you see on the
screen here is to tell you this is a
battlefield zone so you'll switch from
exploration mode to battle mode the blue
zone is your zone of movement so you
move anywhere you want in that zone but
you can also use battlefield ingredients
such as covers for protection so rabbit
Luigi here using half cover or full
cover and we also have what we call team
jump so by jumping or your teammates you
can expand your zone of movement so here
rabbit peach using Mario she's able to
flank the enemy so you can also attack
the enemy behind that cover and expose
them by destroying that cover which is
really interesting internal strategy
because for next turn will be open for
attacks and last but not least
techniques so from defensive ones like
rabbit peach
she'll boost or offensive ones like
Mario's hero site he's able to attack
the enemy even if it's not its turn as
soon as the Emme moves
[Music]
so this is a very core aspect of the
game itself so you mix and match attack
options movement abilities techniques
but we also have other ingredients such
as pipes rabbit pipes so it does give
you a a good move to flank the enemies
so here for example rabbit Luigi goes
into the pipe out of the pipe - the
enemy goes from Mario team jump land
behind the enemy in one single movement
sequence and then finish off the enemy
[Music]
and what we see here is actually a
explosive cover so those have many type
of a super effects and this one was a
push effect so you can push heroes or
enemies out of the boundaries so again
this is just a glimpse into the basics
of game and as you progress into the
game you have more tactic tools you'll
be able to do more combo setups you'll
be able to use different type of heroes
different type of weapons in order to
battle your way through the kingdom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you and that's and that's just a
glimpse into the game itself but first
and foremost this is a project done with
passion with our hearts so it would not
exist otherwise so we just can't wait
for you guys to try the game at e3 this
week for those are not at e3 you'll see
unlike coverage videos and surprises so
have a great conference have a great
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi a match off his mill game director
for Assassin's Creed origins I've waited
a long time to say that almost 10 years
ago I as many of you fell in love with a
game that game took us to the Third
Crusade and we fell in love again when
it took us to the Italian Renaissance
over the years this amazing series has
taken us to the American Revolution the
French Revolution Victorian London and
of course to the republic of pirates for
the 10-year anniversary of Assassin's
Creed for our fans for ourselves and for
all newcomers we wanted to go back very
far back to show how it all began since
Black Flag over the last three and a
half years we have poured our energy our
talent our passion into bringing the
land of pyramids pharaohs and mummies to
life to bring ancient Egypt to life now
Egypt challenged us it fundamentally
challenged us to reinvent what it means
to be Assassin's Creed and over the next
few days you will see play and feel this
reinvented experience I am deeply
honored and proud to be here
representing the amazing work of a
phenomenal team and thrilled to finally
be able to show you this beast we have
been building without further ado here
is a taste of Egypt
[Applause]
[Music]
my lash across the screen
that's with
50 moles
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
to play
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
as an extra treat let's check in with
home base where we're going to get a
glimpse of what you'll see right after
the UB conference hey there folks Chris
waters here at the home base with Hanny
Duong and Carl Lewis producer on
Assassin's Creed origins at Ubisoft
Singapore Carl's here to give us a look
at the gameplay of the game we're going
to be entering the open-world we've got
a ton more to show you but Carl kick it
off give us a little taste here open
world of of Egypt this is the demo that
we will be showing on the show floor
here at e3 byuk is riding into the
volume one of the the regions in Egypt
that's most southernmost region it's a
beautiful area we see we've come in from
the desert moving towards this Lake
Morris and let's have a little
exploration around here using our eagle
see it's sunny on the lake and it's
sunny on the monitor here but folks this
looks really good it's running on an
xbox one exit we've given you the
gameplay feed after the show we've got
thirty minutes of that coming up but
let's see if we can see you from a
bird's eye view what's a new is up to ya
so say no is looking into this military
camp and tagging a few enemies here
after after the show we will infiltrate
this camp and take it out either through
stealth or combat or perhaps range
weaponry alright if you guys want to see
more of this be sure to tune in right
after the conference Kristin I'm Carl
here we'll be right here at will be
joining us as well you won't want to
miss it that 30-minute slap gameplay
feed is coming up after the show but for
now it's back to the stage and on with
the excitement that's it for now
thank you thank you so don't forget that
you can watch this demo in its entirety
after the conference livestream from our
home base and for those of you here at
a3 please come to the Ubisoft booth
where you can live this new experience
of Assassin's Creed thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey piece of chicks
[Music]
[Music]
get our new hotshot driver with a
promising career dominate off-road
racing on his way to the top
[Music]
well there's a skin line there's a wreck
that cutter growing up our champions
weren't around it
no matter what the engine fill they
don't want the track
[Music]
[Applause]
this season's a sports champion coming
out of nowhere to rise to the top
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you two years
back the crew to be driving genre out
there to be wide open world of the USA
thanks to our players we have taken with
iconic vision to the next level they
showed us what the light and what they
wanted to see in the futures now it's
time to take it way beyond driving i am
stefan beret creative director this is
the crew - yeah
Tyger Tyger
yeah in the u.s. motor sports are louder
bigger AG than anywhere else in the
world drivers and fans meet across the
country and celebrate a common passion
for all things motorized now's your
chance to join in ladies and gentlemen
welcome to virtru - of modder nation
[Applause]
[Music]
so you
[Music]
[Music]
in the heart of the city street racers
prove their skills skidding on rooftops
burning asphalt and tuning their ride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
forge your own path off-road through the
striking beauty of nature
[Music]
tame and predictable waves on the open
ocean rapid waters or narrow rivers
[Music]
fearless pirates rules guys spin between
buildings through the clouds among
stunning stunning perspectives
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all across the country
I obtained contest a will to take the
lead on modulation you've had a glimpse
of the crew to register now for beta
access or player Jimo adver booth
experience TC 2 for yourself enjoy the
ride
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
we all started as one team we all wanted
to be superheroes for the same reason
you're a traitor tweek and now you're
with a group of super traitors this was
started by you we are the ones who
walked out of the [ __ ] franchise
mysterion why would the Freedom House
help us
we sent a spy someone in our group who
pretends to want to switch sides and
join freedom past
nobody who they don't know very well
well that's fair in love and war freedom
busy [ __ ] animal you got problems new
kid whatever you did last night got a
lot of people's attention bad people if
you need information just know you can
rely on call girl who the [ __ ] is that
so I guess now any [ __ ] [ __ ]
thinks they can be a superhero we're
gonna rip you apart
dude Mysterio that's 50 Union kids
hello toolshed toolshed is a catchy to
your class visionary architect and a
[ __ ] trader
Eric you must listen to me get out of my
head Timmy your franchise is going
nowhere
face the truth Eric you guys are kind of
douchebags he just called his douchebags
in my mind he did step the fractured but
hoped available October 17th there was a
sort of synergy of what we're looking to
do something interesting in VR and we've
got this division and you're looking to
sort of bring you know what sense you
have of storytelling with him and put
that into the context if he are you can
for the first time as a player feel like
you are in a movie that's a really good
word for it
we want you to take off the gear and
still feel unsettled
[Music]
whilst working with Ubisoft we stumbled
across some fascinating research that
had begun in the late 90s essentially
neuro scientists had figured out a way
to upload brain data trauma emotional
emotions memories to the digital space
now we've gone and taken the next
logical step and with ezel we've
recreated in virtual reality
one such specimen time so we'd like
money to come in join us and experience
the walther test case for yourself that
how do we don't want ever again
[Music]
[Music]
what you're experiencing is a recorded
consciousness it's not like watching a
movie so no matter how real it may say
it can't hurt you
you were completely safe we're
completely safe
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
and now I'm happy to share a new
surprise with you building on the legacy
of one of our most popular world's two
super talented teams of Ubisoft
Singapore came up with something really
really unique so I want you to see that
and enjoy thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
men from all over the world sail the
treacherous trade routes of the Indian
Ocean the riches in their holes fuel
their dreams of power and fortune while
wetting the appetites of those they fear
most pirates
and asides after 70 years
Hawaii goes there for
is to lock the door
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we get a little
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
120 days that's how long the average
pirate survived a lawless life on the
seas during the Golden Age of piracy I'm
Justin faring the creative director for
skull and bones and this is your chance
to not just survive but to climb the
food chain and surpass a legend of every
pirate who ever sailed the high seas
since bring an innovative naval combat
to Assassin's Creed we at Ubisoft
Singapore have set out to bring you the
ultimate pirate experience a tactical
action game where we take that naval
combat to the next level mastering the
ocean and its wins at the helm of ships
armed to the teeth Skull and Bones takes
place in a shared systemic world where
you can sail solo or form a gang of
pirates with your friends and together
terrorize the trade routes of the Indian
Ocean season after season you'll
collaborate and compete with other
bloodthirsty players even execute
ruthless betrayals in order to become
the ultimate pirate kingpin now i'm
proud to share with you the loot hunt
one of skull and bones 5 vs. 5
team-based PvP modes right on right
we've just received Intel that merchant
convoys rich with treasure are sailing
just off the coast of Madagascar but
beware there are other pirates also
looking to plunder the PvP disputed
waters of the Indian Ocean
[Applause]
the Priscilla's shallows of Madagascar
located on the cusp of a bustling trade
route it is the perfect place for an
ambush
here is our gang of pirates the Raiders
going head to head with a gang of rival
players the cutthroats victory goes to
the team with the most loot at the end
of the hunt
knowing how to sail with the wind is a
pirate's most precious skill use the
winds to increase your speed or to
position yourself for tactical advantage
in battle to reap the most rewards it is
best to split up some going inland
others keeping to the open sea
[Music]
each warship has unique strengths the
frigates hull is reinforced its arsenal
equipped with numerous culverin cannons
the Brigantine is devastating up close
with a battering ram designed to break
any resistance the sloop-of-war kills
from afar with its crippling long-ranged
mortars and precise long nine cannons
well this infect open fire nothing will
save you now
wowyou soggy nothing don't let bloodlust
cloud your purpose you're here for the
loop and so are your rivals starter
Goods then back to your station
the team that escapes with the most loot
claims victory
[Music]
searching for more targets on the
horizon our sloop-of-war spots a rival
pirate ship further inland
with its heavily reinforced hull our
frigate swoops in to save the day
bearing the brunt of the damage
another day another victim
ah si vamos coño our gang of pirates is
now taking aim at the frigate and it
will take team coordination to take her
down
now Galen we can take a sir with the
enemy ships broadside now vulnerable our
frigate rushes into border
thanks to blackened silver Betsy smoking
some fish piss
Oh
pirate hunters have been sent in
signaling the end of the hunt they
target the Pirates with the most stolen
loot time tomato oyster captain or we
are good news
still doubtful the pirate hunter
defenses are so strong that the only
option is escaping the Brigantine is
sacrificing herself to buy time for the
frigate who carries the most loot
[Music]
the frigate now needs to make its escape
through the reefs doctor
successful pilots know when to run with
their holes full and the wind at their
backs
thank you all very much I'd like to
invite you to play the lute hunt at the
Ubisoft booth at e3 and please register
for our live phases online oh and one
thing I forgot to mention the world of
skull and bones is one that evolves when
you act it reacts did not kiss the girls
my lips with Rome oldie way will haul
away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mott's maxim that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bah-bah-bah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not the most pretty I'll live
forever sing live with me but not the
one of those with somebody I just wanna
dance with somebody I just wanna dance
with somebody I just wanna dance with
somebody it could be
I wanna dance whistling bah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
with somebody hey everyone I'm bebe
Rexha and just Stan's 2018 is out this
October on all consoles bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you use it as a telephone you use it as
a camera
it's your music player your flashlight
calculator and GPS navigation device but
now finally the most high-tech company
in the world has unlocked the mobile
phones true potential so that it can do
what it was truly meant to do you're
playing cowboys and Indians
hey you kid we need you to come play
with us put on some cowboy [ __ ] meet us
outside and bring your phone
we're playing cowboys and Indians Dickel
Inuits are technically Native American
this new kid with MS Schade
[Music]
these guys a new [ __ ] new kid
so destroy your atlas jewel of the
Pleiades
nova took us to the stars each new world
more incredible than the last
we had no idea what was waiting for us
the legion
which consumes everything in its path
they've never used StarLink before go
show them what it can do
let's do this my god
chase how's it going breaking atmosphere
even the odd
judge we need to buy time for me to jump
start the engine
they are resisting ice barrage linking
fire motor
[Music]
we're up against impossible odds but
together we will adapt
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Matt Rose producer at Ubisoft
Toronto like many of you I grew up in
the 80s obsessed with sci-fi animation
comics and of course all the really cool
toys at Ubisoft Toronto we built a team
with a dream of bringing those amazing
childhood memories back to life for a
new generation
Starlin battled for Atlas allows you to
take control of a team of star pilots in
a massive open living star system
fighting to save Atlas from The
Forgotten Legion build your custom
starship and then adapt to new
challenges on the fly link extra armor
and heavy weapons to take on a huge
Legion prime search for aim since
ancient secrets lost on the worlds of
Atlas or outrun outlaws for an asteroid
field freedom is at the core of StarLink
battle for Atlas collect your way with
both physical starship collectibles and
digital versions available and even take
your game on the go using the power of
Nintendo switch visit Starling game comm
for more information and stay tuned for
many more surprises over the coming
months thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Rebecca kutas I'm the studio
director at Ubisoft ANSI it's a pleasure
for me to be back on stage after our
announcement at e3 last year and we have
had a since then a full year of support
and continuous development of steep
since the very beginning of this project
we have been working with athletes and
we have always been impressed by their
passion and dedication we learned how
one champions with 300 days a year on a
trampoline to practice for that perfect
landing we learned how others make more
than 6 million turns to practice with a
15 they have two racing competition
these athletes they travel to the world
to train with the best to compete with
the strongest and to challenge
themselves with the most experienced and
skilled coaches it's truly a level of
passion and dedication that goes well
beyond our everyday lives and when you
talk to the very best of these men and
women you realize that there is
something they always have in back of
the minds at all times it's a dream that
takes years of preparation for just one
go at that unforgettable moment this
December with our first steep expansion
this is a journey you will take enjoy
[Applause]
as a child you would wait and watch for
fire
but you always knew that you beat form
the word while they
you
[Applause]
that you would change
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was lost but now
I'm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is Dan hey and I'm the
executive producer of Far Cry the brand
as well as the creative director of Far
Cry 5 I'd like to introduce you to hope
County Montana vast beautiful rugged a
place where people don't even lock their
front door anymore but that's how it
used to be today
Hope County's been overrun by a
fanatical cult you find yourself trapped
deep in cult territory cut off from the
rest of the world they closed the roads
there's no cell phone signal no 9-1-1
people are [ __ ] scared I had to say
and just up ahead the small town of
Falls End has been completely overrun if
you're going to survive you and your
guns for hire are gonna need to save it
but to do that well you're going to need
to raise some hell
[Applause]
we got pig damn looks like a war zone
[Music]
lady one
water tower got it
[Music]
I'm in position you're wealthy
we're only dead will you walk in the
light of our Father and
let burn boom [ __ ]
boom-boom-boom-boom
behind you bang-bang-bang for need mohel
of the way world and I love the way to
roll that one boom boom boom
turn it up [ __ ] quiet
Bobo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
where is your master I don't deal with
domesticated I eat the [ __ ] ain't got no
master but I do have your little toy hmm
show me the idol show me the Redeemer
you go mate
[Music]
yoyoyo hand it over
I got a hot date don't do late mmm
monkeys got a date what what what what
what what that's Swiss [ __ ] chocolate
pit bon appetito
[Music]
I want every [ __ ] cop in this [ __ ]
City
hmm after that grab my chassis knocks me
see bro
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] me damn
[Music]
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
it's about bloody time hmm let's see
what we got
[Music]
moksha
just as yama described it true freedom
lies beyond
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
first of all I want to say a big thank
you to all the teams who worked very
very very hard on creating all all the
ESL this world again thank you to all
these these teams behind us I want also
to say thank you to Eve with all my
heart
thanks you for making this happen this
is this is just amazing and also a
special thanks to the fans of being good
and evil for sticking with us for so
long about bloody time 15 years almost
so welcome to system 3 our story takes
place before the birth of Jade in a
multi-ethnic multicultural human society
in a distant solar system it is a time
when corporations create hybrids in
their labs and enslave them to colonize
the stars in order to compete for power
and cosmic resources with our crew of
crazy and unforgettable characters we
fight in the name of freedom and the
right to determine our own fate among
the stars and we will helm massive star
ferrying vessels through territories as
spectacular as they are dangerous we've
been working very hard just on the
technology during 3 years and today we
have a seamless online playground where
we can travel across space at the speed
of light we can explore mysterious
cities and discover undone lands by
ourselves or with friends and we want
you to participate in the making of this
great adventure join our space monkey
program
[Music]
today and help us make beyond good and
evil a world that will challenge us and
bring us together four thousand
adventure thrills and firm and these Eve
just join us this is thank you thank you
okay congratulation you guys you know
Gabriela Michel you've done a fantastic
job
it's amazing what I've been you've been
able to achieve and you and I and all
the teams and the power of creating
games that will amaze all the gamers and
I think video games can help us to grow
and to get better so thank you very much
thank you congratulations
[Music]
so now I would like to thank everyone
here in the room and those who are
watching us from hope thank you for
listening today and thank you for
playing our games so to all the teams at
Ubisoft thank you for your incredible
imagination and enthusiasm all of us
here
we wish you all a lot of fun playing
games this year so thank you very much
and have a great history
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah